well it's a good thing I haven't washed
this shirt since Super Bowl Sunday my
one Deadpool shirt that I can find even
though I technically own three there's a
teaser trailer out meet cable
let's check this [ __ ] out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'll to myself
[Music]
time's up you dumb [ __ ]
well that's just lazy writing brilliant
is so brilliant
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn you know what man I think this
really is exactly what I'm gonna want it
to be
[Music]
this looks so cool
[Music]
three times up you dumb [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh yes yeah I just love that line about
it's not gonna try to remove muster any
quotes that knows I'll do it again that
was that was the awesome man
the Marroquin he still feels just as
exciting is when the first Deadpool came
out I'm loving it so much and in terms
of like the action sequences that we
were getting it's exactly in tune with
what I've been wanting this movie to be
I actually rewatched the first John wick
last week the one that this director
co-directed and all I've been wanting
from this new Deadpool is to have the
same kind of humor don't lose that s
thetic at all don't lose that touch but
when there's action sequences to really
amp up the action sequences to make the
action sequences really stand out
because that's the one thing I felt the
first deadpool movie was missing so as
long as this second devil movie has the
awesome humor plus sweet kick-ass action
and just looking at the action sequences
you're like oh ya know this director is
definitely bringing a lot of his a-game
for the gun shootouts I know the first
one we had to cut back on some of the
gun action because of the production
budget so they had to switch to a lot
more swordplay they got the perfect
director to do it I hope he can just
handle the comedy really well which I
have no doubt he'll be able to but with
the action men look so cool the winch
cable looks great right now Josh Brolin
will be the highest-paid actor this year
dude he's gonna be an official superstar
I mean looking over the trailer I know
we have he saw Vanessa again weasel
blind ow negasonic teenage warhead oh
and this girl Domino Domino's began
teased a lot and I know she's this
mutant who can like manipulate look I
have a feeling she'll be a standout
character and the way how people really
responded to negasonic teenage warhead I
feel like people might respond to her
even more yes it's like we're teasing
that Deadpool is coming back we're
really building up cable right now but
Domino is a character that I'm really
looking forward to I'm really hoping
that she gets a chance to truly shine in
this movie I guess my one question is
how are they gonna balance the tone of a
character like cable in this Deadpool
movie because even in the images of
cable kicking ass I mean it's just a
trailer but in the images alone of cable
kicking ass it looks like cable scenes
are gonna be a lot more serious than the
rest of the movie so I just hope that's
mixed in really well totally for the
entirety of the picture but screw bad
either way even if it gets like a 5% of
rotten tomatoes
I'm getting my tickets opening night I
cannot wait to see this movie alright
guys thanks for tuning in you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell get notified every
time one of our videos is up and check
out our patreon become a patron eject
today it's worth it